suite et fin de notre série en ukraine
avec isabelle et zélie fils les deux
tourangelle préparent leur retour dans
l'hexagone alors que la tension
s'accroît à lviv où elles sont toujours
leur ultime passage à la frontière doit
se faire demain avec une famille
ukrainienne qu'elles vont rapatrier en
france une maman son fils la grand mère
de ce dernier et leurs chiens le
cinquième et dernier épisode de ce
périple en zone de guerre c'est avec
théodore de queiros
bon bah c'est sellal a remis les 85
80 50
les sirènes et on a dit sandy dans
l'abri
une dernière nuit agitée à lviv pour
isabelle et zélie au petit matin une ou
plusieurs requêtes survolent la ville
pour s'abattre à 150 km au nord-est à
l'usc c'est la première fois que les
bombes de poutine en jetant à l'ouest
mais pas de quoi effrayer ses deux
tourangelle qui se prépare aujourd'hui à
l'exfiltration de trois ukrainiens vers
tours un contact des attend c'est que ça
va deux tours et l'ukraine qui nous a
mis en contact avec anastasia qui est
une ancienne de ses collègues et la
situation est un peu critique parce que
son petit garçon est autiste donc ayez
un chien donc ces deux difficultés
supplémentaires mais nous c'est nickel
parce qu'on a le bon nombre de place est
donc voilà un geste on ne sait pas quand
ils vont arriver là ils se sont mis sur
la route donc on les attend
le duo doit déjà s'adapter au régime
particulier de l'enfant à base de
graines de sarrasin
maintien
[Musique]
meyer pour récupérer des dons qui ont
été apportés de france et
japon la fio de cash a donc ça
[Musique]
ça pour hector
plus tard dans l'après midi les deux
familles se rencontrent enfin
reste encore à parcourir tous les six
les deux mille kilomètres qui les
séparent de tours mais aucune frontière
ne semble résister à ces deux
tourangelle pas même celle de la langue